gone but not forgotten the legacy of a
prominent businessman in the hispanic
community here is being remembered
10 years after his passing eight news
now reporter kristen drummond shows us
the impact of edmundo escobado senior
and how his family continues uplifting
latino voices
[Music]
the american dream captured in photos
he has touched somebody in some way
throughout his years here
[Music]
the pictures on the walls inside el
mundo spanish newspaper in the east las
vegas valley
highlight the life of its founder
edmundo escobedo senior
an immigrant who became a pioneer in
southern nevada's hispanic community he
worked very very diligently very very
hard
edumundo escobedo junior reflects on his
father's success
from meeting with u.s presidents to his
modest beginnings in mexico
escobedo eventually crossed the border
into el paso texas
and enlisted in the u.s air force a
decision that eventually brings him to
nells air force base and
his future endeavors here i might
establish a relationship
of working with people helping people
helping the youth
supporting a community by dabbling in
various jobs following his honorable
discharge
escobedo's resume includes being a
promoter
he started being an artist from mexico a
theater owner
we started showing mexican movies there
and activists one of the things he did
do is set an example for
hey you can make money but don't forget
the community
tom rodriguez is an author who's
documented the hispanic experience in
the silver state
there's not been another person like
eddie that much i can
tell you he describes escobedo as a man
of the people
always uplifting the community by
raising funds at events
like the cinco de mayo celebration to
support hispanic
trying to make things better for our
people
and you can't say that about everybody
part of his continuing legacy in the
valley is the escobedo professional
plaza
this location on eastern near bonanza
opened in 1998 to help
growing latin businesses have a place in
the heart of the hispanic community
and that continues today it was very
heartening
to see that kind of development built
there
to serve the hispanic community unlv
history professor
michael green calls escobedo one of the
first major hispanic figures in las
vegas
escobaro's efforts over the years as a
businessman and advocate resulted in a
northwest valley school being named
after him
to me he represents the growth of the
hispanic community here
and the people who contributed to it
those contributions continue in el mundo
escobar's children inherited the roughly
40 year old business in 2010
following his death from pancreatic
cancer they work to give their readers a
voice
we pride ourselves on the core
readership that we have which is the
first generation hispanic
while building on their father's
foundation that all can achieve
freedom prosperity and wealth while
giving back
kristen drummond 8 news now
by the way el mundo newspaper has a
circulation of 30 thousand copies a week
and a total readership of over ninety
seven thousand
now you can watch our hispanic heritage
special anytime
on our website at eightnewsnow.com there
you'll find
several stories about hispanic americans
who have influenced and enriched our
culture